Islam is who everyone said he is the  guy's [ __ ] good no is he good he's  great he made it look easy it was not a  tough fight for him I think the most  surprising thing and if you're not an  Islam fan what you're gonna have to deal  with is not only is he a splash of  khabib on the ground I think he's  definitely could be but hate the  comparison and khabib obviously they're  like brothers and khabib's father who I  think should be the narrative on this  UFC 280 card is the Father's plan he  took these two young boys who were best  friends who grew up like brothers in  that training room in Dagestan Karen  rocks up a mountain wrestling goats or  the hell they're doing he took these two  young boys  and  arguably  out of them from nothing made the two  best lightweights to ever [ __ ] do it